selon le scientifique en chef du québec
rémi quirion le québec et le canada
accuse un retard considérable en matière
de cybersécurité
les gouvernements sont à la merci des
géants que sont google amazon la chine
aussi et des experts ont publié il ya
quelques jours ceux ci un livre blanc
sur cet enjeu de la cyber sécurité
arrive nous pour en parler l'un des
signataires louis roy de raymond chabot
grant thornton de bonsoir
alors quand on dit comme ça qu'on est à
la solde qu'on devient que ce mode
dépendant de gogol de la chine d'amazon
ça veut dire quoi faire pour se baigner
dans la rubrique dans laquelle on vit en
ce moment tout ce qu'on fait toute
l'information que ce soit des achats sur
l'internet des documentations de
formulaires ses stocks et à quelque part
en ce moment que ce soit une entreprise
et la plupart des gens qui contrôle de
l'information sur internet en ce moment
ce sont malheureusement des entités
privées
on peut parler gaffard facebook impose
donc tous les gros joueurs ont beaucoup
beaucoup d'informations sur vous en ce
moment est donc ce que vous dites dans
ce rapport c'est que nous sommes en
retard
nous sommes en retard en matière de
cyber sécurité on est en retard dans la
protection de nos données le livre blanc
pour beaucoup sur la chaîne de blocs en
loin qu'on appelle le bloc chain quelles
sont les conséquences à prévoir du
manque d'avancement sur le développement
de la chaîne de blocs chine mais en fait
l'objectif l'eau du livre blanc c'est
vraiment de démontrer en fait question
les impacts et les potentiels de la
chaîne de blocs là au québec leur
particulièrement en fait je voudrais
dans un contexte où la chaîne de blocks
amène beaucoup déficience au niveau
transactionnel met inouïe économique
donc il ya des enjeux économiques
importants là
ondo transactionnel la partie fiables
sur les recommandations spécifiquement
en fait lorsqu'on recommande la
recommandation principale lorsque le
gouverneur du québec quoi l'état du
québec en fait tu dois reconnaître je
voudrais la technologie rich and the
block et des registres distribué comme
étant incontournable au niveau
économique et iliad maillon d'une
stratégie claire pour le futur
spécifiquement des incontournables en
quoi cette technologie là est
incontournable mais en fait c'est
partout ce qui sape apportant quelque
chose à son application peut être très
très large mais son regard dur au niveau
financier les gains d'efficience des
processus au niveau des paiements en
trop que ce soit aussi au niveau de la
traçabilité
donc nous ce qu'on recommande c'est
vraiment que le gouvernement en mettant
en place en fait stimule l'innovation
spécifique à la technologie bluemotion
et peut-être également de mettre en
place des chantiers des chantiers sur
tout ce qui touche le cadre légal et
réglementaire de loin ou de près le haut
niveau la chaîne de blocs qui inclut les
actifs numériques que ce soit également
au niveau du talent comme dans plusieurs
domaines et pas seulement un outil il ya
un manque de talent et également de
stimuler avec des projets pilotes par
tuyaux québec sur des projets de bolton
intéressant que ça pourrait être un
nouveau de l'identité numérique moi que
ça pourrait être un nouveau tu vois que
ça pourrait également au niveau de la
traçabilité des produits agricoles au
québec entre autres donc donc beaucoup
d'opportunités l'heure donc des
opportunités pour mieux protéger nos
données ou est effectivement mieux
protéger les données puis également allé
de l'efficience c'est ça qui est
intéressant avec la tête du dow jones et
à la mine de livres 100 dans des
processus soit deux par l'élimination
des tiers par suez environnement des
confins de transactions mais plusieurs
intervenants meet a tall gibelot chain
dans un concept d'avoir des registres
distribuerez il ya beaucoup d'étapes qui
seront automatisés donc le fait des
lignes et des sciences a réduit le
risque de perte de données de vol de
données
si tout cela est bien programmé dans
font six autres grippes sont conçus
adéquatement initialement ça n'a pas
beaucoup de sécurité dans les processus
l'enfant est ce que la chaîne de blocs
éviterait
devise convient avec les codes vol de
données dont on a parlé dans les
derniers mois
en fait tout ce qui touche la sécurité
que la chaîne the block c'est différent
en ce moment la pression ça fonctionne
on connait des grandes grandes
entreprises doit gérer la sécurité des
informations qu'ils détiennent donc ça
devient un centre de faiblesse
potentielle
quand on regarde les registres des blocs
de chiens deux blocs s'est décentralisé
je voudrais en matière de registre en ce
moment et rien de plus sécuritaire
qu'elle soit nous votre technologie
en ce moment je voudrais les enjeux de
sécurité c'est plus autour du registre
donc si on regarde spéciquement des
actifs numériques donc la faiblesse du
système c'est paul rigide ce point
central c'est tout ce serait comme moi
le détenteur d'actifs
donc comment je gère l'accès mais actif
personnellement donc si quelqu'un
m'attaque la personne doit avoir accès a
misé informations et mes actifs mais ne
repas excellent sens les informations
qui sont dans le régissent alors qu'en
ce moment là qu'on garde quand les
informations et centraliser
c'est quelqu'un attaque un organisme
central mais c'est réussi à pénétrer
dans l'organisme travers l accès à toute
l'information exacte c'est un concept
intéressant c'est un concept intéressant
le vous dites que le gouvernement du
québec a pris du retard
on sait que le gouvernement du canada et
la banque du canada s'intéresse à
définitivement en fait le gros du canada
l'été dernier dans le cadre de sa
révision de ces lois service et tout ce
qui est numérique en fait fait la
promotion d'être plus une en innovant
donc les cinq lui l'intelligence
artificielle c'est un clic à mal la
technologie de chine deux blocs
bon ce cadre est intéressant ce qui est
des projets concrets je vous dirais rue
main est un projet qui s'appelle jasper
sont déjà rendus à l'étape 3 de ce
projet là en fait c'est un projet
premier l'efficience tout ce qui est la
structure de paiement au canada
oui donc les uns sont financées à la
participent à ce projet là et vous avez
sûrement entendu parler aussi
dernièrement eu comme échos que la
banque du canada travaillait le pôle
émission de l'un d'eux
de tokyo de dollars canadiens numérique
donc moi parce que moi je crois c'est
une question d'être une question tant
les points de cyber monday munci
l'harmonie ou en fait ce serait une
monnaie digital virtu donc ça serait
complémentaire ou notre bancaire ou à
l'argent qu'on procède en ce moment et
on a ramené numérique des volumes très
bien louis roy s'arrête ici merci
beaucoup merci merci bien pour cet
entretien ce soir